j'ai des souvenirs enfants et jeunes
adolescents d'avoir été très complexée
physiquement à la piscine notamment
[Musique]
foot ou collège où j'étais jamais celui
qui a été choisi parce que trop mauvais
[Musique]
des souvenirs enfants et jeunes
adolescents d'avoir été très complexée
physiquement à la piscine notamment dans
les vestiaires mais piscine où j'étais
très pudique et je comprenais pas
l'impudeur qui régnait dans cette pièce
là mais au foot ou au collège nous était
jamais celui qui a été choisi parce que
trop mauvais et évidemment moi je pars
du principe que c'est une naissance à
ces enfin un moteur assez essentiel
voilà d'être confronté à ses limites
d'être d'être oued être d'être
confrontée à l'hostilité du monde
extérieur
je crois qu'en fait on se nourrit ont
grandi de sa et de rien d'autre
et finalement d'avoir été comme ça
relativement même grossièrement complexé
ça m'a permis au contraire quand ma prof
de français qui je dois beaucoup qui
s'appelle madame écart un qui m'a fait
faire du théâtre pour là première fois
j'avais treize 13 ans je crois et elle
m'a fait monter sur scène enfin sur
scène devant l'estrade devant le tableau
noir au lieu de nous apprendre à réciter
platement molière m'a fait jouer les
fourberies de scapin devant tous les
élèves et je me suis totalement révélé
la bonne ans alors que j'étais tellement
timide jeunes gens dormaient pas de la
nuit je faisais mais comment je vais me
débrouiller de cette ici cette histoire
de cette affaire est en fait ma
officiers finalement j'ai vite compris
que mon atout n'était pas le sport pour
le goût mais le théâtre et de voir dans
le regard notamment des jeunes filles de
ma classe les voir me regarde et
totalement différemment mais regardez
avec sourire avec avec joie et ça a
totalement changé ma vie quoi et je
pense que je pense que l'enfant que
j'étais avait compris que mama ma force
ma différence était peut-être de
m'exprimer plutôt que de m'illustrer
dans des dents des sports dans lequel je
ne pouvais pas ministre et
je pouvais pas faire la craie créé date
ou quoi donc j'ai fait 2 2 mais des
avantages un avantage en m'exprimant à
travers le théâtre par exemple ma fille
fait du piano depuis quatre ans j'aime
l'idée est qu'elle fasse du piano est
elle aussi et je me fiche de savoir quel
est son niveau en fait ce que je veux
c'est que ça la ronde joyeuse le jour où
ça ne la rendra plus joyeuse à ce que la
force serait plus ces mêmes c'est son
retour de classes d'écoles ou de classe
de voile avec deux classes vertes ou de
vacances avec ses camarades et ce qui
m'importe le plus c'est déceler toujours
une une joie dans ses yeux et voilà ce
qui me semble être pour moi le plus
important